Hello, welcome everyone. It is October
15th, 2025 and we are in active guest
stream number 82.6 continuing with the
Robert Warden series. Today, Robert will
be presenting and we will discuss a
unified theory of language part one. So
if you're watching live, please write
any questions in the live chat and we'll
address it after this presentation. So
thank you Robert for joining to you.
Okay. Uh can you hear me?
Yep.
Okay. Well, this is Robert Wen here
talking about a unified theory of
language. Um
this is a summation of what I've been
doing in language for several years now
and it's in a paper on archive which you
can go to and it's quite a long paper.
It's about 50 pages actually. So this
talk is in two parts
and uh I'll introduce what is coming in
each part in in a minute
right now.
So the talk is really about all of
language and language is traditionally
uh looked at in terms of these different
areas. There's phenology is how sounds
fit together to make words. There is
syntax there is how the words fit
together to make utter utterances
uh statements and questions and so on.
There is semantics how utterances
express meanings.
There is pragmatics and that is how we
carry on conversations with each other.
How we understand what each other is
going on in conversation
and those are the four traditional
areas. Then of course there is learning.
How do we learn to do all of this stuff?
And finally there's evolution. How did
language evolve and why did it evolve?
And the two columns at the right speaker
and listener column are empty but they
are there to remind us that in every
question in language there are two sides
to the question. There's a speaker side
how the speakers do it and there's a
listener side how to listen understand
what's going on. And finally, um the
evolution row at the bottom. Um I
believe this uh phrase, I don't know who
said it, that nothing in biology makes
sense except in the life of evolution
and certainly language. There's a lot to
say about language evolution. And I
shall be saying that in in two parts in
both these talks.
So
here's what I'm going to cover roughly
in the first of the live streams.
language
um I shall say is works by hierarchical
basian pattern matching in other words
by minimizing free energy so it's it's a
a ripe area for the fe to be applied
it's quite a complicated area because
it's not just pattern matching many
thousands of different patterns are
involved there's we have one pattern for
every word in our native language
and the state-of-the-art now is there
are working models of phology ology,
syntax and semantics. The situation in
pragmatics is not so clear. Um anyway,
these working models have been developed
in what cognitive linguistics
and I shall be taking an approach that
uses cognitive linguistics, not chskin
linguistics.
And in cognitive linguistics, every word
is represented by what's called a
construction. And a construction is a a
graph, a feature structure pattern.
And what we do when we speak language or
hear it is we do basian pattern
matching. And the particular word in con
cognitive linguistics for that pattern
matching is unification. And that's been
developed for a long time now for a good
40 years that idea has been in
development.
And we learn language by a different
operation on feature structures which is
called intersection. And that's a kind
of complement to unification which I
will talk about.
So all of that is a model of language
which works at David Mars level one of
requirement and level two of abstract
algorithms and data structures. It's not
a neural implementation
and I regard the neural implementation
of language as a problem yet to be
solved.
So that's what I'm going to talk about
in the first live stream and pragmatics
I leave entirely to the second. Now just
a brief summary of the second live
stream of some kind of foretaste.
It's all about evolution. Language
started in conversation. That was the
earliest evolution of language. Simple
conversations.
And language evolved by sexual
selection, not just natural selection.
And that sexual selection to do a
particular thing to show off our
intelligence. And that's why we are so
intelligent actually. And because of
this language is not the neutral system
that people think of. It's rather biased
and it's about social status.
And in any conversation we use
special patterns for mind reading for
knowing what the other person thinking.
So that's theory of mind. And then I
will be mainly talking about pragmatics.
Pragmatics I shall say uses the same
kind of basin pattern matching as we saw
in this live stream for syntax and
semantics.
This model of pragmat pragmatics
addresses both the speaker side and the
listener side of the problem that is
new. So we learn these mind readading
patterns and in those patterns we have a
thing called a shadow audience which is
our imagination of the other person who
assesses our own status and that idea of
shadow audience is the whole basis of
the human sense of self.
Now the human sense of self is obviously
very important because it's the basis of
all human society but I shall say it's
the greatest affliction. It is a great
deal of trouble for us as well and I
shall describe why it's trouble and
affliction and I shall finally talk a
little about mindfulness which is a
release from this human self. So that
was a foretaste of the second live
stream but enough of that we'll come
back to the first now and we start with
the first in evolution.
So language evolution is a question with
two parts really. One part one is what
is the underlying cognitive capability?
What's the mechanism in the brain that
does it? And second how did language
actually evolve in particular one
species and no other species. So this
talk first part addresses only part one
of the question and the answer very
simply is that language is hierarchical
basian pattern matching that as you know
is a capability that exists in all
mammals.
So
hierarchical basin pattern matching in
animals is the set is this sort of
hierarchy bottom level we have features
of sense data edges sounds and motion
and so on. Next level up, those features
are integrated into parts of objects,
things like limbs and leaves.
Next level up, the brain
classifies these into whole objects like
food or animals or plants. And finally,
at the very top level, we have the full
generative model of three-dimensional
space around the animal which is the
basis of consciousness.
So that is what the hierarchy looks like
in typical applications of the free
energy principle on animal cognition and
there are many FE models of this and as
you know it's a a joint top down and
bottom up inference process uh getting
the two consistent with each other and
there are FE neural implementations of
that. So a lot of work in the FEP on
that. Now going on to language.
This is how language has a similar
hierarchy. The bottom level hierarchy,
parts of words, syllables if you like.
Next level up, those integrate into
words.
Next level up, those words are
integrated into utterances. And finally,
individual utterances are pulled
together in conversations.
So that's the hierarchy for language and
joining the levels of the hierarchy of
the different topics in language.
Phenology puts phone names together and
make words. Syntax and semantics put
words together to make utterances. And
finally, pragmatics is how utterances
are put together to make conversations.
Now,
as I say, I think this is a very fertile
area for the FE.
Are there any FE models of this? Now, as
far as I know, there aren't because most
of the work on the in the FE on language
has been in the Chskin tradition rather
than in a cogen linguistics tradition,
which is much more akin to this
hierarchical pattern matching idea.
It's quite hard to do. There are lots of
patterns to be matched, but basically
this is an FE application and I don't
think it's been done yet in cognitive
linguistics.
There have been FE papers on chumpskin
linguistics but um
those are different. Now there is a
longunning dispute or feud between
chskin linguistics and so-called
cognitive linguistics. Now cognitive
linguistics on the left has been
developed since about 1975 or 80 by a
large number of people. Gerald Gazdar,
Kaplan, Ronald Langaka
and many others. And it uses
unificationbased grammarss. It makes
computational models. It has
constructions which are called fe which
are feature structures.
And each construction has two poles
which I shall go through all of this in
in some detail and that is cognitive
linguistics. On the other side there is
generative jammer grammar and there is
been a long running dispute really
between workers in cogn linguistics and
followers of chsky and generative
grammar. You will recognize many of the
uh memorable slogans of generous
generative grammar. It started a long
time ago with transformation deep
structure.
It has this idea of poverty of the
stimulus that the learning stimulus for
a child is not sufficient to support
learning of language. So because the
stimulus is inadequate there has to be a
lot of innate grammar in the mind. This
is revealed by language universals and
there is a syntax module in the brain
which has autonomy which is a module on
its own has nothing to do with other
parts of the brain.
And you know there's a chkin distinction
of language competence versus language
performance. And the story of language
evolution is quite a strange one. The
chskin story is that there was a kind of
miracle mutation that language arrived
on one individual called Prometheus uh
in one generation about 200,000 years
ago by a miracle mutation, a hugely
unlikely mutation. So that if you like
is chosen linguistics in a in a in a
nutshell. There are there's been loads
of ideas throughout the years. Now I
believe that constant linguistics has
been much more successful
than chomskin linguistics for two
reasons. It's built much more working
computational models
and they really do work for many
different languages. and is confronted
much more empirical data about language
whereas chsy and linguistics they
haven't built very computing very many
working models and many of the core
hypothesis have been shown to be
incorrect in other words just go through
those in a bit of a detail
transformations deep transformations are
no longer believed in the idea of the
poverty of the stimulus is discredited
there is plenty of stimulus for a child
to learn language. So language
universals turn out not to be universal.
There are always exceptions.
There is no alternative syntax. Syntax
is
irrevocably mixed up with semantics if
you like. There is no actual competence
versus performance distri uh
distinction. Performance was a kind of
convenient way of being able to uh
ignore a lot of the data if you like.
And there is no idea of a miracle
mutation need to account for language.
So um I shall be firmly on the side of
cognitive lingu linguistics and I shall
be advocating that work in the FE should
take that approach to language.
So what is cognitive linguistics? It's
also called construction grammarss and
this has been a successful model of
language since about 1980. And in this
model, every word is represented by
what's called a construction.
And there are larger constructions for
phrases as well as words. But each
construction is at a logical level a
directed asyclic graph, a DAG.
And
the preconstruction has both a fanatic
pole has two poles. a phicic pole which
consists of the sounds at least in the
sounds of a word and a semantic pole
which consists of the meaning of the
word.
So that's what constructions are. You
combine these constructions in a
sentence by unifying them. So
unification is the key operation
and that operation handles both speech
production
and speech comprehension. In other
words, it does both sides of the
problem. The speaker's problem and the
listener's problem. And this approach
handles phenology, syntax, and
semantics. So, what I'm going to be
talking about in this part of the live
stream is really work that evolved over
the past 40 years, 40 or 50 years.
There's very little that's actually new
here.
Um it's just
so
one of the things I shall refer to is I
have made an online model of how
cognitive linguistics handles
s pragmatic error phenology syntax and
semantics and the model is available
here at baze language.org or so I would
urge you to go and look at that
demonstration to see the things I'm
talking about actually demonstrated in
many different examples and this online
model does production and understanding
of sentences for a number of simple
concrete sentences up to half a dozen
words each. So what this model does it
converts between meanings and words in
both directions. Speakers go from
meanings to words and listeners go from
words to meaning.
And the way it does it is it does one
unification for each word in the
sentence. And you can see the
unification happening.
It has about 100 words in it and you can
use those words to make up your own
sentences and see what it makes of them.
And it's also a model of learning. It
can learn these words from scratch
starting with no language models. So I
should be referring to this model and
using diagrams from it when I talk.
Right?
So here is a construction a typical
construction in construction grammarss.
It's a construction for the word girl
and it's got it's a feature structure.
is a graph as you can see it's pregraph
in this case and it's got various type
nodes and the phonetic pole is just the
sound of the word sound girl and it's
actually broken up into phonemes she g
uh but that's not expanded
and the semantic pole is the meaning of
the word girl and the meaning of the
word girl is a person one person and
it's young and is female so that is a
typical example of a construction in
constructed grammarss.
Nouns are the simplest constructions
because the phonetic pole consists of a
noun consists only of the sounds. It's
pure phonetics.
Now if we go to the next more complex
thing for a verb like drinks here you
find the phonetic pole is more
complicated. The phonetic pole has the
sound drinks in the middle but it also
has two other things. It has a subject,
the person doing the drinking, and an
object, the thing being drunk. And it
needs both those things to make sense.
So the venetic pole in this is more
complicated. And the semantic pole is a
scene in which a person is doing some
drinking of a thing. And these curvy
lines
are links which make the
construction into not a tree a directed
is ascyclic graph. And I've pulled them
apart in order to pull apart the venetic
pole from the semantic pole but in a
sense they share some nodes. And what
these curvy links do is they move
meaning. And when a listener is
listening to a sentence
and they unify the sound drink, the
meaning of the the meaning of the
subject must be there. The meaning of
the agent, the person doing the drinking
has to be there in advance. And it moves
that person
from there down into the final meaning
scene. Similarly, the thing being drunk
has to be there as well. The curved link
moves the meaning down into the drinking
scene. So that is the etic pole and
semantic pole for a more complicated
kind of word construction. In fact, all
word constructions
have this pattern uh with several links
one zero or more links across between
the phonetic pole and the semantic pole.
So how do we speak and understand
language in this model?
Um, this is the most complicated slide
in the in the talk and it illustrates
how we understand a simple sentence, a
two-word sentence. Uh, in this case,
doggy runs.
And the starting point is top middle.
And you can see the the listener
listening to this sentence, doggy runs,
starts off with only the sounds. And
there the the phone names doggy runs are
listed vertically.
And what the listener first does is it
unifies this. The listener has a number
of constructions in her mind and she has
a construction for the word doggy. And
that consists of the phone names doggy
and the meaning uh which is a thing of
type dog. And what the listener does is
to unify this word doggy with the
initial sound. And the result of that
unification is here. What's happened is
that the matching parts, the doggy part
has matched between here and here. So
they've been shaded out because they
match and the meaning of the word doggy
has been imported in here and the
remaining parts of the sentence are
unchanged. So that is a result of the
first unification. And you can see
what's happened. Unification is always a
growing of patterns. It always makes
patterns bigger.
So that's the first step of the
unification. And that result of step one
is pulled down here to the middle of the
bottom. And the next step of unification
is to take the word for runs, the
construction of a run. And this has a
complicated phonetic pole with both the
thing running
the top and then the sound runs and then
a semantic pole here. And now we unify
these two together and we match up on
the sounds runs and runs. So what we get
now is all the sounds have been matched
up and are grayed out. But what we've
produced the bottom here the bottom
meaning scene in which it is a running
act and the thing that doing doing the
running is a dog. So the listener has
understood what the speaker said. Now
that's a unification model of
understanding.
There's a very similar unification model
of language production. And in
production,
you've seen in understanding, you always
match up the sounds. They m match the
phonetic poles and you add the semantic
poles. In production, you go the other
way around. You match up the semantic
poles and you add the sound poles. And
so you start with just a meaning and you
end up with a whole load of sounds that
you can express, you can say.
And so the order of unification has to
be reversed there that you start with
the verbs when you're producing and then
you end up with the nouns. And again,
unification is a way of growing the
structure so that you grow from pure
meaning to a meaning and a sound. And in
this case the curvy links move the
meaning upwards.
Okay. So that is the construction
grammar cognitive linguistics model of
how we speak sentences how we understand
them and as I said you can see them in
the demonstration where I've given you
the link. Um finally
um no I'm switch now. So how does this
relate to the FEP? It relates because
the operation of unification which has
been around in cognitive linguistics for
40 or 50 years that is a basin pattern
match. In other words, it's a
minimization of free energy and I'll
explain briefly why that is.
The construction graph for a word has a
certain information content and the
information I is the sum of the
information in all its nodes and slots.
So you can go around the graph looking
at the information all the nodes and
slots and you add it up and that simply
is the information content but it also
represents some situation in the world
and the probability of that situation is
2 to the minus i. Obviously the more
information the more improbable the
situation is.
Now when you unify two constructions A
and B
that's written C equals AU B. And how do
you form C? To form C you as we've just
seen you match up A and B wherever
possible. Wherever they have the same
slots and values and you're not allowed
to have any conflicts when you match up.
So you keep the matching in the
unification C. keep the matching parts
and you keep both non-matching parts
from A and B and that's why unification
is a growing operation
and the result of this is that C the
result C contains A and it also contains
B
and C is the smallest graph which has
this property.
In other words, of all the graphs which
do this, C has the smallest possible
information content. So it has the
largest possible probability 2 minus i.
So it's the basian maximum likelihood
match of a and b.
Equivalently it's the minimum free
energy matching of a. So unification is
just a free energy minim minimization
process.
Right now the demonstration which I've
told you about also does language
learning. I'll talk briefly about how
that works. There's another operation
you can know on on two constructions and
it's called intersection and you write
the intersection by this funny upside
down U D A U B. Now, how do you form D?
Again, you match up A and B wherever
possible.
Now,
you keep the matching part and you
ignore any non-matching parts. So in
other words any slots in A and B that
are different you just forget those
slots. So the result of that is that A
the structure A contains B and the
structure B contains D
but D is the largest possible feature
structure which has this property which
is contained by both A and B. So D has
the largest possible information content
that's the intersection operation. Um
intersection is essential for learning.
The reason it's essential is that what
intersection does is it projects out the
common parts of two states of affairs
and it throws away the rest. And that's
what you need to do in learning. Uh
language learning is a whole lot of
individual
sentences, situations you hear and you
have to project out what's common
between those in order to learn. And
I'll just briefly describe how that
happens.
Bootstrap learning by intersection.
Suppose a young child has heard learned
some words already A, B, and C, but
hasn't work learned some new word X.
So she hears a sentence which contains
the words A, B, and X.
That means she can do part of the
understanding process unifying and B,
but she can't unify X.
So she does what part of the
understanding process she can do
producing a large feature structure and
she can also observe what's going on.
She can infer the whole meaning from the
conversational context from what an
adult is making a gesture or there's
some food on the table or whatever it
may be. She can guess the meaning on a
reasonable proportion of those
occasions. She gets the guess right. So
she puts the partially understood
sentence together with the guest meaning
to produce what I call a learning
example. And this is denoted by L1.
And she collects a small number of these
learning examples L1, L2, L3. All with
different A's and B's, but all of them
having the same unknown word X in them.
Then in her mind she can do the fixture
unconsciously of course she can do the
intersection operation between these
feature structures L1 intersect L2
intersect L3 and now what turns out and
you can show this mathematically is that
the intersection is just the
construction for the new word. In other
words that intersection is the
construction feature structure for X.
So she learns a new word and and that
way she can bootstrap actually from no
words at all learning nouns first
uh as children do to learning a full
vocabulary and full speaking ability. So
you can see how this works from the
demonstration which here is the URL for
demonstration again. So what this shows
is that the chskin idea of poverty of
the stimulus the idea that there's not
enough information to learn from is just
a myth.
Right, I think I'm getting fairly
close to the end now. Um,
this model of language, the cognitive
linguistics model is a
model at Mars level two. It's a abstract
set of algorithms and data structures.
The abstract data structures are the
feature structures of but it's not a
neural implementation.
It uses hierarchal basin pattern
matching but there is no neural
implementation of it yet as far as I
know. Now I think one could implement
this in the FP and one could start on
neural implement implementation of it
and I think that's a very important
problem to try. I would dearly love to
collaborate with everybody in doing
that. I think there are a number of
challenges in it and here are the
challenges that there are thousands of
word patterns to be matched. Not just a
few buttons, a thousand. So you have to
rapidly selectively retrieve a few
possible match patterns to see which one
match best. You're always looking for
the best fit. So there's some fast
selective retrieval needed. And that if
you get to the unification operation,
it involves a discrete search space as
well, a continuous search space. So
ordinary gradient descent is probably
going to be a rather inefficient way to
do it. I don't know what is the
efficient way to do that unification.
And finally, the graphs that you use
here are dynamic ones. Feature
structures are dynamic tree structures,
graph structures. How do you model those
by static neural networks? Now, I just
don't know the answer to those
questions, but I would very much
appreciate it if anybody wanted to
collaborate on trying to produce an FE
implementation of language in this way.
So, I say I don't think it's been done
yet because I think most of the FE work
on language has been in the Chsian
tradition rather than the cognitive
linguistics tradition.
So that is actually the end of part one
which is took less time than I thought
but so here's a summary of part one of
this um live stream language works by
hierarchical basian pattern matching and
there are many thousands of patterns
and in cognitive linguistics this has
led to working computational models of
phenology syntax and semantics and these
These are in lots of different
languages. It's been done in lots of
different languages.
It covers up to semantic. It doesn't yet
cover pragmatics. That is uh another
subject for the next talk.
So
every word is a construction. It's a a
feature structure graph. It has two
poles, a semantic pole and a phonetic
pole. The key operation is unification.
And unification is basian pattern
matching or equivalently it's the
minimization of free energy.
The same model can do learning by
intersecting feature structures
but this is all at Mars level two. The
neural implementation at Mars level 3 is
a problem still to be solved. I do
invite anybody to collaborate on
tackling that problem.
So that's what I've covered so far and
pragmatics
is the
key gradient which will be addressed in
the next live stream. So I finished
ahead of time and uh
for questions I guess.
>> Thank you Robert. Do you want to share
the baze language.org demo?
Um, yeah, I could I could do that. Um,
>> yeah, that might help
>> clarify.
>> Okay, let me um
go to it.
Take a few minutes. Um,
>> yeah.
>> Yeah. Meanwhile, if anyone Yeah. has
questions, they can write it in the
chat. So I will bring that on screen.
Okay, go for it.
>> Okay, so here's the page you land on if
you go to that and and slide sets and
papers there. But actually to run the
model, you do that and that's what the
model looks like and you got various
menus at the top. There's a help menu
tells you how to get started and so on.
And you can look at constructions for
words and there's a whole load of words.
So you take G
right take the word like him
and there you have the construction with
its um phonetic pole here and as you
hover over nodes you get explanation
what's going on.
Um, so there you can look at words.
Um,
and here you can look at a few sample
sentences. You can make your own
sentences, but I've got a few samples
here. And there's the one doggy runs.
There is all their fragments of
sentences.
Like we have a complicated one here.
Girl who fell.
And that's the meaning.
That's girl who fell is the sound part
of it and the meaning part is a scene in
which a thing which is a girl does an
action which is falling down.
So what you can do with that sentence um
if I can get it is you can try
understanding that sentence.
Let's see what I don't seem to have
enough
uh not sure.
Yeah, I have to manipulate this a bit to
get the buttons to show here. Right, if
I want to understand this sentence,
then we start with the whole sentence.
Girl who fell and you can either expand
or or contract some of these. This is
contracted, right? Girl who fell and
there's the word girl which you unifi
unify first. So you ask it to do a step
and it does a step of unification
and that's the result. So you've removed
or hidden the sound girl and you left
the sound who fell but you replace girl
by a scene in which there's a thing a
young female thing. Then you take the
next step
which is fell.
There's the result of your first step.
And there's the word fell. F E L for L.
And it's a person going on a downward
path. And you ask it to do this step.
And the result of that is you've
eliminated the the fell sound. You just
the only sound you got now left is who.
But here there is the girl and here is
here there is fell.
So you step again
and that is the word for who. It's a
rather complicated one. It's got a
couple of links here. It says
something who something did some action.
Then it it combines the curvy links
combine the actions.
So that's the word who and that is the
result of the second step of
unification.
Um and you ask to do the third step
and you get a final meaning which is a
person who is falling.
So that is quickly how the demonstration
does language understanding.
You can do the same thing for language
generation. And finally, you can run it
through an automatic learning sequence
where it can start with no language, no
words at all, and it builds up knowledge
of first nouns and then the other parts
of speech in language.
Okay.
>> How does it parse those first nouns? Or
is that based on entity recognition?
>> Um, well, let me let me go to that. Um
let's try and do that.
um autolearn. Uh I want to do a word
sometime since I used this actually I'm
we take a noun
apple
there's the construction it has to learn
apple.
Now I think
we're unscripted here so may go wrong.
Um,
I can't
learn that word. That's a that's a pity.
Um,
the learn button doesn't seem to show.
Doesn't seem to be activated at the
moment. So, um,
what I can do is autolearn.
So, it uses a bunch of words. There are
some random learning examples.
And there are nouns.
And there are adjectives and verbs and
and
there are some verbs there and some more
verbs here. And um
I think
when I press this button again.
So what it does is it goes through
random learning examples.
Uh, example one is hot apple.
Example zero is Anna ran. She saw Tim
saw hot apple. My green apple fell. So
what's happening is that it's producing
the meanings for this. The child is
observing the meanings and doing this
intersection operation and the child has
there's a one example is hot apple. My
green apple fell. So the child produces
collects a number of learning examples
including the word apple and does the
intersection operation and each time the
child observes the meaning going on
which is my green apple or apple fell or
whatever it may be and observes the
sound apple. So when the child does the
intersection, it projects out the sound
apple and it projects out the meaning,
the round edible thing. And so the child
learns the word for apple. So I'm sorry
I couldn't demonstrate that in more
detail, but perhaps if you go and
experiment with the demonstration,
you'll find out um how to show more
detail there.
>> Okay. So there's a a juxtaposition
and an associative learning at the phmic
and the conceptual level and those get
unified into what you're calling a
script.
>> Yeah.
>> And the script is always the top node of
a constru of any feature structure.
>> Okay. And the scripts are also
composable
in that trains of phone names can be
recursively parsed for their for their
>> for their ling their lexical elements.
And then that gets parsed in a way that
is
>> not exactly the Chsky and sentence
diagram but more like a cognitive
ontology about the causal relationships
reflected by verbs and other parts of
speech.
Yeah, it it's built on animal cognition
where animals can recognize a scene and
recognize uh what's doing what
and that nonverbal pausing is the way
you build up the meaning part of
sentences.
Uh, if I just have a a slight um,
I saw him
for instance. So that meaning structure,
there's the sound structure and there's
the meaning structure. And the meaning
structure is a sort of pre-existing
animal cognition. Animals can pass
scenes into structures like that.
We've added the sounds.
>> What are the scenes? They they also seem
to be composable. And there's active and
inactive scenes.
>> Yeah, that's right. The the scenes with
just things in them. There are scenes
with action going on. Yeah.
>> So, the lower scene where act is false
is because it's just the fragment him.
Yeah, the lower scene is just describing
him
>> and then the the the composed scene is
saw him
>> which is an action because it has a
>> verb is action of seeing and it's time
in the in the past tense.
I mean th this particular diagram
notation
uh is in some sense not very important
because
they could you could have other ways of
passing
the world into scenes. You could have
carved the world apart in slightly
different ways. The same principles
would hold. You still get fix structures
and you still have unification as a way
of combining them.
So there's one kind of almost
introspective optimization about pattern
matching a new stimulus to previously
recognized stimulus and doing a kind of
detection whether it fits exactly to
what you've seen before or making some
kind of thresholding decision like
whether you're willing to accept a fuzzy
match or going to generate a new
template. But how do you connect that
kind of
knowledge
optimization with the reduction of
uncertainty
about the ecological semantics
like the uncertainty distribution of who
was it that saw him or what is it that
they did with him?
How do you represent those uncertainties
or questions
which the semantics of these diagrams
end up providing information on?
Well, I think the semantics of these
diagrams
is it comes from animal cognition and
animals have an ability to pass a scene
into things and actions and recognize
the importance of those things and
actions. you know, animals sees a
predator or sees something approaching.
It's passed the scene into predator and
and movement and so on and so forth. So
all that is built on animal cognition
and is not new for language. What's new
for language is we pair that in
arbitrary ways with sounds
and we build those bigger feature
structures that have a sound part as
well as a meaning part.
But the whole animal thing is animal
prior and
animal evolution has has made animals
categorize the world into those
categories
and we have a huge number of categories
that we carve the world apart into
before language.
Do you think this helps h how do you
feel that this advances or helps give a
new perspective or direction for
linguistics which already has many
ontologically structured sentence
diagramming approaches
and work at the the morpho syntax
interface
with like how phonemes get associated to
to terminology.
>> Well, I I don't think this is new. In
other words, all the work on
linguistics, people like Jackandov
who've done work on lexical semantics or
many people have worked on it and
there's a whole consensus of of all the
work they've done in cognitive
linguistic linguistics started in the
80s and this is just pulling that
together in a working computational
model.
And I mean I'll tell you the the new
parts of this first live stream are not
the language production and language
understanding that has been being going
on for years in cognitive linguistics.
The new parts are the language learning
part is new and the basian
interpretation linked to the FEP that is
new.
So just summarize again how how would
you connect this or numerically to the
FEP? How do we go from this structural
qualitative map to quantitative
information dynamics?
Um well that goes back to
the slide but if you build an FEV model
of animal cognition
um
which is
visual cognition surveying a scene
classifying things into
features and objects
and the whole of that top- down model
and you link that to language.
The the meaning part is conventional
FEP.
I get back to where
in other words um this this diagram here
is
it there's loads of FE papers about this
and that is the semantics side of
language what's new is is linking it of
the word sound is the word phonetics
and that's been going on in cognitive
linguistics. It it's kind of not new.
It's been going on for so long for since
the 1980s. That's what cognitive
linguistics has been done. It started
before the FE and the two have converged
if you like that they can be seen as
basically doing the same thing in the
domain of language.
Yeah, there's an initial ingress
unification processing from either
visual edge detection in the case of
reading or phonemes in the case of
listening
that move into a a possibly
>> very well behaved
composable cognitive space.
That
is what we tend to see in these
hierarchical generative models
like whether it's the reormalization
group type models or just other other
nested models or coarse grainings
and
>> yeah any multiscale yeah
>> yeah multis and then part of the
challenge is
um
in the situation where nested models
represent
spatial or temporal enclosure,
you're dealing with a divisible
concept of space. So the the clustering
from centimeter to meter is similar to
the nesting of meter to kilometer.
However, so so that that tree only has
like one kind of branch if this were a
nested spatial model. But when we are
>> it also has the branch that the spatial
model comes up to classified things like
insects or animals or vegetables or
whatever. And so it's that
classification in into discrete things
where the contact with language occurs,
>> right? Language presents itself with
many more kinds of edges, not just the
the lumping and splitting of a of a
homogeneous field.
into different units of resolution. But
it actually is the question of where and
how
the specificity and the semantics of
different objects get reflected
either in the biological substrate or in
a computational substrate. So I'm just
looking at, you know, this gray pen.
It's not immediately obvious or there's
multiple implementation strategies
how there could be um just just to kind
of give a um two options. There could be
a color node where the the
value of the color belief is gray.
Or there could be a grayness andor there
could be a greyness node where the
belief quantitatively is like yes.
Yeah. That that's the kind of
representational ambiguity. We don't
know the detail of how colors are
represented in in language or in minds
before language. Um but language has
evolved to do the things that people
find useful. In other words, if we live
in a community where it's worth having
shades of gray, we will develop words
for shades of gray and children will
learn the words for shades of gray. If
we live in a community where the only
uh contrast we need is dark gray versus
light gray, then we will develop words
for those and children will learn the
words for those and it'll be a different
structure that gets learned.
>> Yes. And then there's the sort of a um
the the natural history and the systems
engineer path whereas the natural
history can do different gain loss
change of functions to explore in that
marian or the tinberen framework.
What kinds of architectures are embodied
by biological systems? How do they
represent space? How do they represent
color? What are their constraints on
different kinds of beliefs and updating?
Whereas there's a bit different and
freer of a hand in the systems design
because even as we're just discussing
that there's there's a plurality of ways
to represent
even
basic
declarative semantics.
Yeah. And so you can have
>> Yeah. There's a whole story here that I
haven't gone into at all. That is that
word construction
evolve over human generations by there's
a natural selection process for words.
In other words, if a word is making a
useful distinction, if the word pen is
useful in our society, then that
construction survives as it replicates
through generations.
If the word quill is no longer useful,
then it goes extinct. So that natural
selection process is superimposed on
real natural selection and happens much
faster. And that's the way languages
change that the constructions evolve by
a very fast selection process.
>> Yeah. to to that and I think on the
learning and evolutionary so within and
across generational
constraints
there's an analog of
drift selection mutation balance
where you could have one linguistic
environment
where there's a flat distribution you
you have drifts and you just have terms
just change, nouns change, and things
swap out.
And then the other extreme would be a
heavily selected linguistic environment
where there's more of a
um
like truncating selection on incorrect
language.
>> I I believe we're more at the heavily
select for linguistics. We're more at
the heavily selective end. In other
words, there are strong selection
pressures on words and all sorts of
selection pressures. Useful meanings,
simple pausing, lack of ambiguity and so
on. So words come and word word species
come into being and get extinct very
rapidly within 10 generations or
>> Yeah. Uh uh agreed. and also that even
the generational change we observe is
built on a embodied causal substrate
that's older than the mamleon. Um I'm
really curious about what you said in
the beginning about the shadow audience
as our human sense of self. So how would
you relate that to theory of mind
thinking through other minds and what
does that mean that there's a shadow
audience?
This is the part that interests me most,
I guess, and it is for the next live
stream, but I'll give you a flavor of
it. When we're talking to someone, any
conversation,
we have to reply appropriately to what
the conversational partner is saying. We
have to work out what their what what
their intention is. So, when I ask you a
question,
I am assuming that you will know that I
need to know the answer.
So that's the theory of mine. I I ask a
question, I immediately infer that, you
know, I want an answer. And that's a
typical piece of theory of mine. But
because language is about social status,
I'm thinking not only about what do you
think about this conversation? I'm
thinking, what do you think about my
social status? Do you think I'm being
impolite? Do you think I'm being
insincere
or whatever? And so that's what goes on
in conversation with you. You are the
real audience. I use my theory of mine
which is basian pattern matching to
infer what I think you are thinking
right now. So that's when I'm speaking
to you live. When I'm offline thinking
myself, I'm imagining what what am I
going to say to Dan this afternoon?
Then I imagine you and I imagine what I
say and I imagine your reaction to it.
Dan will be offended. Dan will think I'm
stupid or something like that. So there
you are my shadow audience
in my mind. I've conjured up a shadow
audience and I think what's that shadow
audience going to think of me? So that's
the origin of my sense of myself is what
I think other people are going to think
about me.
So that shadow audience was born in
conversation. You know it evolved in
conversation because I have to carry on
conversations with people. I need to
rehearse those conversation in private
thought. So when I rehearse any
conversation I have a shadow audience
and I imagine what are people going to
think of me if I say that.
So that's all for what the next talk is
about.
>> Yeah, that's quite a line
like how will I be seen or understood
but then who am I?
>> Yeah. And I believe the human sense of
self which is much more developed than
chimpan chimpanzees have a certain sense
of self. They can see themselves in a
mirror. But monkeys can't even recognize
themselves in a mirror. I think most
animals just don't have a self in that
human sense. And the human sense of self
was born with language.
And it keeps society functioning
together. I mean, that's why society
works because we're all thinking about
what other people are going to think of
us.
And that doesn't necessarily need to
entail an individual level emulation
like explicit counterfactual theory of
mind. It can also get
I would I don't know about sublimated or
sedimented into just heristics for how
we engage with groups.
>> It it I think it's not so much heristic.
It's always quick subconscious pattern
matching. If I say that, he will think
this and it's not a thought I have. It's
something that happens before I say it
and stops me saying it. So, it's very
quick and it's learned and it's
sometimes wrong. You know, I think
people who admire will I think if I buy
a Ferrari, people will will admire me.
Now that thought is actually wrong, but
it leads a lot of people to buy
Ferraris.
Yeah. And from this belief updated
hierarchical generative model
it is possible to
you can imagine a variety of other
mental operations
like you can sample phone names or
sentences from lower down in the tree
that are consistent with the upper part.
You could imagine varieties of
counterfactuals
of of how things could be differently.
You could combine this with a action
model with a with a causal world model
that could connect to those
counterfactuals.
And then we would basically be in the
setting of calculating the expected free
energy and assessing different courses
of action in terms of their epistemic
and pragmatic value.
Yeah, I mean the these things all
filtering up and down the hierarchy
basically from the phonemes of what
somebody says to you to
the top of your hierarchy of the
self-esteem my position in society and
they're all linked in one big
preconcious inference.
This pattern matching is going on the
whole time and it's subconscious
basically. Well, you have consciousness
here at the 3D generative model layer,
but
>> yeah,
>> of course,
>> there's a lot of consciousness around,
but the actual understanding a sentence,
you're doing unifications about five per
second, and that's too fast for
conscious thought.
And so, you're also having ego reactions
at at two or three per second. You're
having eager reactions faster than
conscious thought.
It's all quick basian pattern matching
big picture. I yeah I am still left with
the that pattern matching is just this
internal kind of library science almost
like there's a request coming in and
there's going to be some internal
process to match and either accept a
stringent or a fuzzy match or make a new
entry.
However, there's a second level
semantics which is the reduction of
uncertainty, minimization of surprise
regarding
the message of that request.
Yeah. Does does that message fit into
the context right now? Um that's the top
down fitting
top down and bottom bottom ups happening
all the time.
So what will we look forward to in two
weeks?
Um basically
it's how language evolved, why language
evolved
and language as I say language evolved
by sexual selection to show off
intelligence and get mates. That's
basically it. So because it's showing
off intelligence, it's all about social
status in the group and the theory of
mind part of language carrying on
conversation all about self-esteem.
Um
and basically pragmatics
how we carry on conversations has been
if you like the poor relative of
linguistics.
Everybody sub studied syntax and
semantics and they have nice systems but
pragmatics has been very much less
developed since about 1980 and in
particular
people studying pragmatics don't look at
both sides of the problem. They haven't
looked at the speaker's problem as much
as the listener's problem. Pragmatics
has been all about what the listeners do
to understand in the context what the
person is saying and it's not been about
what the speaker does to get himself
understood in the conversation. So the
next lecture is largely about pragmatics
and evolution.
Then it leads on to the human sense of
self and human nature.
>> Very cool. Anything else you want to
say or or ask on this one?
I think it's an awesome unification work
and I I out of the corner of my eye see
the kinds of graph
technology developments
that would help us make these types of
agentic or orchestrated knowledge graphs
that have elements of linguistic
semantics and quantitative graphical
models.
and those methods
um to to be able to to do assembly and
parsing of those more rapidly
to support some of these.
I I'll read one question from the live
chat. Robert, so Mills 8102 wrote, "I'm
thinking about how we have different
modes for different environments, home,
workplace, recreation, etc. I wonder
what the effects are of maintaining more
or less of these modes on someone's
adaptability.
I in in the context of language I think
that's absolutely right. We do have
different personalities and different
ways of presenting ourselves
linguistically in different
environments. we have, if you like, a
different vocabulary for work versus
home versus
sport or whatever it may be. And so that
is one dimension uh that when we go to a
different environment, we switch in a
different set of prior about what words
we're likely to hear and what people are
likely to mean by
Okay.
Well, people
>> can I just end with one appeal? I think
lang end with an appeal that language I
think is a hugely productive area for
the FE and I would very much like to be
involved in any FE implementation of
language along the lines I've sketched
and to try and take it right down to the
level of neural implementation
that I think is a hugely promising and
challenging research project and I'd
welcome anybody wants to collaborate on
it knows more about FE than I Awesome.
Thank you, Robert.
Till next time.
>> See you then.
>> See you.
>> Okay.